hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trendsenses.com
so i want to make a video where i will
do something
very new so i usually do some technical
analysis on gamestop on
amc i'm gonna do the same but this time
i'm gonna actually try to see what
happens if i
invert my chart upside down and
try to apply the same rules to see if
i would find another conclusion that
would for example tell me that actually
gamestop would go
lower let's get into it
[Music]
alright guys so this is the first time
i'm gonna do something like this
and i think it's very interesting to
basically test
idiot wave theory and test kind of
technical analysis
and trying to basically use the same
data
that i'm having here and where i applied
all my iliot wave counting
that gives me with almost no doubt the
conclusion
that this would go higher so once again
guys i don't know exactly when
but what i see for now is that you know
the market is crashing i mean the nasdaq
the s p 500 i work in asia on the
japanese markets on the nikkei
the nikkei is just getting destroyed
guys hammered every day
right now i took a day off for you to do
this video but i checked the market
and the nikkei is dropping again so when
i'm gonna go to work i'm gonna have a
lot of
stuff to do but whatever i want to make
something funny guys look at this chart
so what i wanted to tell you is that i'm
impressed that you know stocks like
gamestop that you know are
kind of overvalued i mean it's not kind
of they're completely overvalued but
it's fine you know technical analysis is
here to tell us
if something is going to go higher or
lower not depending on the fundamentals
you know and
i don't care that it's overvalued i
still think it
would go higher but here i'm impressed
that the stock is actually holding so
well guys all right
because you can see that you know the
whole tech sector is dropping
heavily so i'm not sure we can consider
it as a tech but
i guess yes and gamestop is holding
actually quite well guys all right
around 145
area so it's basically close to the
levels it used to trade you know
in the past month so it's kind of
impressive i think
this is a very bullish sign but whatever
here look what i'm going to do guys bam
invert the scale
so right now
i'm having something that is
upside down and it's the first time i'm
i'm actually watching
it so i still have my countings and here
i'm gonna try basically to
see if this is possible that here we had
heavy drop
all right this market got destroyed
completely
and now it's trying to bounce back all
right
so i'm gonna see if i would be a buyer
of this
so the first thing i would do let me get
rid of all the drawings
so i would make a trendline here
i would first go on a daily to have a
better visibility
you can see that this market is dropping
very
heavily okay so on the daily time frame
i would connect things like this
and then i would try to do some counting
so here
i would have around this area
breakout level so let's put it
okay 110 you know it's funny i'm gonna
find the same levels
just you know because i'm doing the same
thing but upside down
so here i wouldn't be a buyer here
definitely if i see a breakout
here i would wait for something like
this you know just on a daily time frame
attack attack attack attack i would wait
for something like this
if i want to enter gamestop so inverted
gamestop
on the long side so basically if i need
to short game stop
i would waited for to break the 110 area
and then i would buy
sell back the retest you know whatever
just the other way around
all right so this is one technique i'm
gonna keep doing this
then you cannot connect this in this it
doesn't make sense um we can still try
but you know those are definitely not
the same
waves all right it's not the same
pattern so then i would do some idiot
wave counting
so we'll try to find my waves so what do
i have here
definitely here i have a one two three
four
five very clean
then i have an abc
all right and then
the question i'm having is what's that
all right so i know this is our complex
correction but i'm trying to analyze it
i'm trying to see what i can fit so this
is exactly what i'm doing guys all right
so here then i would have one
this is my two that i'm trying to
underline three four five all right so
this is my scenario then i'm having
where i have the chart you know on the
right side
and this is my one two now you recognize
it all right and
so i'm just trying to do my two but
let's do things
fully guys and let's imagine that this
is wrong let's imagine that this is a
new move
up which is possible that we started
here
one two three four five all right
i can find a way to label it here i
would have my abc corrective
fair enough but what's that
what's that guys this is nothing this is
not
a motive wave motif waves are clean so
i already see that we have problems this
might be a one
okay maybe this is a two
all right we could do something like
this so then
here i'm having my second wave and this
is a triangle
and this is the same triangle i had on
the other side okay but second
wave can't be triangles all right so i'm
suspecting it maybe to be a flat
would this work let me go back on the
let's zoom in a little bit go on the
flowers time frame
can i make one two three four five here
this is not working i'm not allowed to
do this because here the third wave is
the shoulders guys
so this counting is not correct so we're
having some issues here with this
first wave first thing
and here we definitely have a triangle
and triangles cannot beat second waves
so this might be a zigzag
flat all right so let's imagine this
wave one
is valid here we having a zigzag which
is possible then here we're having a one
two three four five
so this is what one two three four five
one
two
all right so this is the alternative
scenario if i want to
believe this is bullish this is what i
would
actually try to find so we probably
would have a correction
back to the 160 level then go to 110
bounce back and go back so let me now
invert again
all right interesting
okay so this is pretty scary guys so
this is the scenario i would have if i
invert the chart and guys you can trust
me it's the first time i'm doing this
right now with you so i'm discovering
the results
because you know i just don't have
enough time to prepare
this and do it you know in front of the
camera because i need to go to work
in two hours and i still have some
videos to make
so what can we say here we can say that
we must be aware that this
is on the table all right let me invert
it again
and you see when we actually look at
things
the other way around we see the
alternative scenario
but once again i need to remind you guys
that
in this scenario my wave one here is not
nice
first thing so for the scenario to be
confirmed we would need to break the 110
level right so first let's see if we go
there
let's see what happens here but
definitely if we break the 110 level
i would have no other choice than
turning bearish as long
as this is not happening so let me
invert it again
as long as we stay above the 110 level
i am bullish and i prefer my other
scenario
that i'm gonna show you guys quickly
here
okay my other scenario is
this is a one this is a two
three four five all right so this is my
other scenario this is corrective
here you see it's better because this
one fits much better guys you can see
here one two three four five
and here i'm having this complex
correction so
this is for now my preferred scenario
but as you guys just saw
we need to keep in mind that there is an
alternative scenario that might
actually go back to very low levels
and the breakout level that is giving me
everything is the 115 level all right so
as long as we stay
above this level we are safe we are
bullish
so that's it for me i hope you guys
enjoyed this video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button
so you're gonna be the first to know
when i upload anything new
and stay close to show i see you guys